mañana ya se cumple un mes desde que se
estrelló la avioneta en medio de la
selva de Colombia concretamente en el
sur del país dos semanas después
encontraron que los tres adultos que
iban allí fallecieron sin embargo hay
cuatro menores de edad que Siguen sin
encontrarse Aunque cada vez hay más
pruebas de supervivencia usted
precisamente estuvo en el sur del país
que se conoce hasta ahora Así es las
fuerzas militares devolvieron Esperanza
a la búsqueda tras anunciar haber
encontrado el lunes una huella fresca es
la imagen que vemos en pantalla donde la
pisada de la niña se compara con la bota
de un soldado una prueba que se suma a
las anteriores como un pañal un tetero
unas tijeras y hasta una fruta Tropical
consumida cerca de 200 militares e
indígenas participan en el operativo con
más de 1.250 kilómetros recorridos que
sería como ir de Bogotá a Quito y
retornar hasta la frontera entre Ecuador
y Colombia los ahora se concentran en un
área de 30 km desde que apareció la
avioneta el 15 de mayo dos semanas
después del accidente vemos en pantalla
la que sería la posible trayectoria de
los niños primero hacia el suroccidente
a una selva totalmente virgen nunca
antes pisada por el hombre para luego
desviar su rumbo hacia el nororiente por
todo ese camino es donde los militares
han encontrado las pruebas por lo que
incluso el comandante al mando Pedro
Sánchez ha dicho que han llegado a estar
a 100 metros de los niños en lo que ha
definido que es como Buscar una pulga en
una alfombra y es que es bastante
difícil poder encontrar estos cuatro
menores de edad en medio de la selva
lluís pero bueno a pesar de la
dificultad están adelantando estrategias
innovadoras para poderlos encontrar
Cuáles son estas Sí el caso se ha vuelto
de lo más mediático tanto en Colombia
como en el mundo recordemos que la
noticia escaló especialmente el 17 de
mayo dos días después del hallazgo
cuando el presidente Gustavo Petro
tuiteó que habían encontrado a los niños
una información que tuvo que desmentir
al día siguiente desde entonces fuerzas
militares gobierno e indígenas
participan en un cooperativo cuyo lema
es buscarlos hasta encontrarlos desde
helicópteros de hecho ya han lanzado 100
kits de comida incluso 10.000 volantes
por las zonas en las que podrían estar
Pero además en los últimos días han
instalado altavoces y reflectores que
llegan a oírse y verse entre 500 metros
y un kilómetro de distancia una
estrategia para atraerlos en una selva
espesa y densa donde siempre nos dicen
que es de noche y en la que llueve 16
horas al día esto Cómo no en una
colaboración histórica entre fuerzas
armadas y organizaciones indígenas
acostumbrados a la desconfianza hoy
trabajan en unidad para encontrar a los
niños